and can you look at a cartoon and come
up with a voice
well like with happy feet i i got to be
like i played two different characters
initially three but then there were that
the one voice sounded too familiar but
when i got to play an argentinian
penguin i used to play the little
machismo penguin you know the guys the
argentinian guys are going
what do you do you know you want it
what dog you're looking at you know you
want to look at it don't be afraid of
the flippers i love you
i brought you some pebbles just some
bling baby you want some bling you know
you do
yes you're hot and you know i got a beak
that'll make you feel so goo
and then you had like all the crazier
ones you know
talking about animation uh we got people
on our audience uh
to draw cartoons of themselves
now i'm sensing self-esteem issues
now oh no now god forbid when i ask to
see this woman in the audience
that she looks like this you better not
put that up on a camera
i will be on you like [__] on velcro
okay show the picture this is the lady
now her name is jane hayes shane hayes
now let's have a look at jane in the
flesh jane jane you're
beautiful jane jane you're not a gay
black basketball player
spirit thought for sally jenkins and i
think her husband look at sally
where's kelly suffers from paper clip
kit
oh sally you look quite buxom
with your funny little terrier ears look
at you oh
and for some reason you've drawn a penis
on your own face
where's she done that she's done a piece
with two tiny bowls
and are those those that i don't know
there's two upside down bells
[Music]
oh my god is that your husband dave
that's that's you
yeah yeah are you are you naked as well
yeah
what's that strange line yeah but more
importantly what's peeking out here
are those your two balls going i'm down
here
and why did you have an accordion for a
neck oh yes
it was the woods with the knife
yeah who else have i got oh actually i
quite like to see this woman
uh stephanie jack where's stephanie jack
hello stephanie jack
there's definitely jackie in the flesh
and here she is in the cartoon
[Applause]
this is a great japanese anime character
mr titular to come to your house
she had a big eyes come to your house
with a large breast open the door with
her nipples
mr bouncing breath follow the bouncing
breath
wow that's kind of what can i have this
one yes you can
been on the road for a while
why were you having the was it a deep
tissue massage we're having
where are you going with this green were
you having a turkish massage or
something
i don't know what it has to do with what
we're talking about but it's a funny
story tell it
i had an awful experience having a
turkish massage
where this guy's idea
of massage was to like
take my one leg and and the other arm
and try and connect it
behind my back and i was kind of like
you know like that and then i well his
belly went in my mouth
it was like a little borax moment and
you know when you get something weird in
your mouth and you're like if you're
eating something you go like you said
your brain sends your tongue to figure
out what it is
it's not a conscious thought it's just
like is that a bone figure that out the
time goes in to figure it out
my tongue was like what is that it's a
hairy belly
sounds like you're heading off in
newspapers
now emilia clark did you get to chat
with everyone backstage
um yeah kind of did you get to talk to
him yeah kind of maybe
emilia clarke loves matt leblanc
hi hi
actually blushing um yeah i just think
you're wicked
it's a game of two halves i think
dominic's wicked
baby in the corner are you returning the
favor do you watch game of thrones matt
i've watched it the first season and
then i kind of fell out of it and i
tried to watch it this is okay that's
okay and i don't know what's going on
there's lots of stuff going on much
going on there is
[Music]
and it's bigger than ever yeah whose
laugh is that
that seriously sounds like a chicken has
been released into the studio
they can't be is that i was going to
stop because i thought there was a
mechanical fault with something
but that's a human being
oh is it that man there all right well
i'm glad you're having a nice time
yuck it up i promise
i know no i know i do have one select
request from you though
um so would you would you be able to ask
me how i'm doing oh
[Applause]
you can say no everyone will hate you
but you can say no
no yes uh well since they you know
haven't been up up to speed on the show
thank you
how are you doing yeah i caught that
it's from back there
it didn't work yes it is there's some
scenes where
they will play music maybe a bit of if
it's a wide shot and it's not like
so it's the closest we get to sort of
kind of
sort of just sort of going forward in
one piece
and they'll play music or something and
my temptation is always just to try to
make the cuddle laugh so sometimes
i'll do things like when there's a
moment where i'm meant to
you know orgasm i'll be like
[Laughter]
see people do that out of the way if
they don't
they should it's like a ryanair flight
when a ryanair flight lands
[Laughter]
when people travel you know they collect
things postcards dolls a national dress
but you collect like animals like
like living animals well no i don't
collect them i
rescue them oh okay so
did you rescue anything when you were in
sicily and tuscany
not in that one but in the movie i did
right after in bulgaria i i did
okay and i had i had promised my husband
i was going to stop because
at the time i had 10 dogs five
parrots i had alpacas horses
cats and by the way one without a tail
the other one without a leg you know
and they always they find me they come
to me these animals which he doesn't
believe me but they do and i promise him
no more okay we were up to 30 animals
i swore no more and and i was there and
a little poppy who was
abandoned and was gonna die i won't tell
you the sad story because it's a comedic
show and i'll start crying he came to me
and i couldn't help it and i picked him
up
and his name is ochoa after the the
goalie of the soccer team in mexico it
was a welcome
and i took him and then i was terrified
how am i going to explain this to my
husband i promised i promised
and um so i came up with this brilliant
idea to pretend that i was having an
affair
um and then ochoa
no with somebody to make him think i was
having an affair and at the end i would
say no
it's not an affair i picked up a dog and
then he would feel better
this is clever good man so i left him a
message
you must call me at this time we need to
talk it's very important
and i never do that and this time okay
what happened what happened and i said
listen i
feel so terrible i don't
know how to say this to you and i know
this is not
not going to go that well and i'm really
nervous and
please have mercy on me you have to have
patience be understanding
it's just it's been so stressful and i'm
so tired and i was so
lonely here for so many days and you
know you do
crazy things when you're in this state
and he said to me
oh please don't tell me you picked up
another dog
one of the things you can do is you can
conjure up uh people's fears yes
okay yes so you you're afraid of quite
basic things
i'm afraid of like most things like
anything high risk i'm terrified of
but those are rational things okay
irrational is like spiders because but
they actually
um i become paralyzed when i when i have
a spider in my room
really yeah i like wish i were tougher
than that
but i'm not okay now mark ruffalo were
you
serious when you told us what your fear
is i mean it is it's a good fear
it's i think it's a founded fear i think
it's a founded fear it is
tell us what it is um i have a phobia of
being chased around with poop on a stick
that's fair yeah
it started when i was a kid
it was just weird parenting
some reason kids thought it was funny to
stick a stick and dog poop and chase
each other around with it
but that scared the crap out of me
because of the cleanliness problem of it
no spreading germs
[Laughter]
jeremy renner though yours is
brilliantly specific
and i think without knowing it i think
we probably all share it
we may i don't know i i didn't have the
the fear when i was younger because
we've all we all go through this but
it's when
uh a little child and i'm the oldest of
seven kids and i got a lot of little
rugrats running around
and they these little roaches start
losing their teeth and they get a little
wiggly and they like to show me like
this little dagger
flipping in and out of their mouth and
like look how cool jeremy want to pull
this thing out i'm like i get out of
here you're freaking me out
but don't you think that is really
freaky it's like her thumb
it just really kind of grosses me out
the cutest little thing on the planet
starts to do like the creepiest thing on
the planet and i'm like get out of here
like here tie the string to my thing to
the doorknob like get out of here creep
disgusting
that's now no little ones running around
flipping their little fake teeth falling
out look we all have this
you know when you have the dreams your
teeth fell out i don't know what it
means anybody know what it means
we get bigger ones no
you have bad dreams am i the only one
that has bad news
a friend of mine a friend of mine just
had that dream too yeah
maybe i'm just afraid of my teeth
[__] falling out
[Applause]
what are you afraid of well i was gonna
go with flying but i think i'll go with
um girls over 12.
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the last minute of my life i wouldn't
have predicted that
how was it mark ruffalo you're not going
to believe what he said to me
he was bang on the money
he was a very perceptive man
it was the dora don't try and justify it
do you know what i've always hated the
hulk he's [__]
don't make him angry yeah you wouldn't
like me when i'm angry ruffalo
my son said that to me the other day
when he was mad at me
what that you wouldn't like i always
hated the hulk i think he's [__]
what is the hold that the spice girls
have over you
is this real yes it's real
and and i just feel like i've been
talking more about the spice girls on
this press tour than i have about the
movie
i did australia i know i wept did you
really weep i really did but now which
one was talking to you
melby and was she really talking to her
was it a message no it was a video
message on an
ipad and that made you cry yes
were you jet lagged yeah but i also
you don't i mean i you do understand
because we're in the uk yeah i was
i was a fiend i was obsessed with the
spice girls
and they taught me about girl power and
i
love them i think they're fantastic
there's so many jamie there's so many
how's it going spice up your life every
morning spice up your lunch
hey there's so many and they're so
fantastic and today on the radio
um mel c talked to me over skype oh oh
so it's really very exciting okay who
would you say is your favorite spice
girl emma bunton baby spice
she's your favorite she's my favorite
who's next
just a question all of the other four
so emma bunton well emma buntin was the
one that i had blonde hair and bangs and
my name obviously is
now emma my name was emily but it was
taken
when i became an actor um and so
now it's emma and uh yeah i just i
i love so give me this so you one gave
you a video message and one talk to you
on skype yes
what are you telling me you've never met
are you going to are you going to do
something
have you never switched are you going to
do something really have you never met a
spice girl um
wait hold on i have to mentally prepare
myself
have you never met a spice girl not in
the flesh
okay now as you know as you know
as you know emma it is very rare it is
very rare for more than one spice girl
to appear together
[Applause]
for any reason at all
[Music]
so they're not here
you